what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down with Donovan sharp I'm back
it's like I I tell the people turn off
your phones it's like he's like the
women on the Pod yeah a little worse
well well the thing is is I'm actually
addicted see I usually I have all of my
notifications turned off except for the
ones that when I when uh when I make a
sale on the TSR Academy store by the
which by the way by the way there we are
we're having a 50 off use a promo code
new 50 to get 50 off everything has been
repriced and all that jazz follow me on
YouTube Donovan sharp and Instagram
Donovan sharp TSR my guess is that as
soon as I get to 10 000 followers again
they'll probably ask my edgy so get away
again they took away your IG before yeah
dude I've lost two instruments maybe you
should just I've switched to just
lifestyle pictures you know what I'm
saying like you can't you can't put too
much no no not really I'm so tired of
them taking it away I'm like it's just
let's just you know selfies in the
kitchen you know it's where I belong
there you go I've lost um I've been uh
I've lost just I've lost two YouTube
channels two Instagram accounts uh I
lost one I actually had lost two but
then Elon Musk gave me back another one
I even lost to do it I lost a uh uh
Vimeo that's a paid that's a paid
subscription they took me down teachers
are coming the Deep State dude it's
ridiculous so you know so anyway follow
me while you can because I won't be here
for long
wow so we go way back yes we do we do we
do you want to tell them how we met oh
my wait no no don't tell that story okay
all right now are you sure about that no
okay I I let's just say he reacted to
one of my videos I reacted to one of her
videos
um and uh and then I actually brought
you on and uh you know we discussed
things together that was actually pretty
cool because Devin ended up coming on
and talking I love talking yeah I love
Devin me and Devin are besties now this
is interesting I think the reason why
you wanted to talk to Devin it was
because you wanted to see if okay
Donovan says she does this and she's
like that what does she really like you
know because a lot of like I I talk
about Devin a lot and people just don't
believe that she is the way she is
because you would say something like oh
my gosh like I didn't love her the most
yes and I was like you put that on on
Instagram yes and I was like who is this
girl that she's totally cool with her
her man talking about he loved his ex
more than her I'm like ah well well
here's the thing and explained it well
and and I'll explain it yeah
um a man can the best relationship a man
will ever be in is it has got to it can
never be with the woman he loves the
most let me repeat that the best
relationship a man can ever be in can
never be with the woman he loves the
most and the reason for that is because
if you love a woman that much you are
you are unable to do and say what needs
to be said and done and so Devin I love
her to the moon and back but right off
the top of my head I can think of three
other women that I have loved more than
her so as a girl do you think we should
go for guys that loved other women more
than us
or the woman's point of view so like wow
because I always think of it from the
women right so if I'm if I'm going for a
guy and he has an ex that I can tell he
really really loved like and is that is
that a red flag or a green flag um you
know I if you
Jesus that's a really good question well
the woman that I loved the most was that
crazy story I told you about the trailer
park right yeah so Devin does not have
to worry about she does not have to
worry about her I think that's an
interesting question I think a lot of
women would a lot of women would love to
think that the man that they're with
loves them the most but when it comes
down to it man like yes men we have egos
and all that good stuff but women you
guys have bigger egos than we do as far
as the love game is concerned so much in
fact that if a man actually has the
audacity to stick his dick in another
chick oh my God even though he takes
care of me you're the girls on fresh and
fit they ask him all the time okay he's
Rich he's ripped he takes care of you
you're driving a G wagon you know you
had a five thousand dollar a lounge you
got American Express black cards you
never have to want for anything
and if he cheats on you with If he if he
sleeps another woman oh my God it's over
the ego is so the ego is so big with
women that was the hardest thing for me
to get over too that was really hard
like because I don't know I just grew up
in a family where like cheating I know
no one in the red pill believes me but
my dad my dad's a different time it was
a different time you know
um I don't know if necessarily it was a
different time this is your father what
this is your father it was definitely a
difference well I mean but it was still
the 70s or eight when they met that's
after free love you know like oh my God
Jesus Christ you know what I mean
they're like 70s or 80s it's not like
well my dad was born in 65 so they were
like he was like 20 something so I don't
know your dad was born in 65. yeah my
dad yeah oh well you're oh you're
younger than me of course my mom and dad
are young yeah okay all right yeah so my
dad my dad was like what you're 45 you
said I'm 45 my father is oh boy 62 ish
yeah so my dad's like 55. but that's
what I mean like is it a different
different time if you're 45 and you
experience sure like 10 years you know
yeah yeah like I just think like certain
people I don't know what it was I think
it's just better I think it's just
better for a woman not to know uh the
reason why I put it out there is because
I want I wanted to impart upon people
that yeah it's great if you love a woman
and you do anything for her but that's
not the woman you want to be and we
don't love them no like we don't love
the guys that like loved you the most
yeah which is which is yeah the one
that's a very good point the woman you
love the most will not love you yes she
will never love you experience like I've
had like the person I'm thinking of it's
like that that's who like she she dumped
him do you know what I mean there you go
but it's like it's like the I don't know
I feel like that guy will like never get
over you know yeah that's that's just
now maybe not never because men and
women like when they look at their exes
I feel like it's different how so like
okay
how do I put it
like men that will value like if a
girl's been there for like 10 20 years
yes where a girl it's like if she misses
an ex and like feels like her ex is the
one that doesn't get over and she
marries someone else like I think she's
more likely to just f up her family and
leave were the men like they I don't
want to say they don't do that but it's
not as common no it's not nearly as good
I can't think of any story that that's
happened but it's like all the leading
love stories are women like Titanic The
Notebook like women love those movies
and it's both them effing it up yep with
the guy that loves them a lot like one
girl was engaged the one girl and they
both I mean I know the guy in Titanic
kind of was freaking out at the end yeah
but but you see what I'm saying like
yeah like both of them are in good
situations screwed it up for an accident
it's like why did so many women resonate
with those movies well because it's
because of the Romanticism think about
it
um uh Cal who was uh Kate Winslet's uh
uh fiancee he was he was a little old he
just he was a little older but he was
rich right like she was taken care of
the Heart of the Ocean diamond and 56
carrots and all that and you know
Hollywood romanticizes Hollywood
romanticizes oh you know the the young
starving artist who's hot and blah blah
blah let's just say the Titanic did not
go down let's say the Titanic did not go
down if Rose moves to New York with Jack
Dawson that would have [__] everything
up their marriage she would have left
she would have dude she would have left
his ass and gone right back to Cal and
Cal would have said [__] you I gotta I
got a younger hotter you yeah that was
dude Titanic is total [__] okay you
know what's funny even as a kid I hated
Titanic yes because I thought I mean
whenever I first saw it I think I was
over the age of 12 so I don't know how
old I was right but I remember thinking
like that Titanic in the notebook were
both so stupid because I've always been
me you know what I mean so so I'm like
she wasn't in love with him she was in
lusts like I remember saying this to my
friend right because I'm like you knew
him for like a couple days yep and now
you're screwing him in the car yeah
it wasn't like a Model T or something
like that and then she jumped on the
boat for this man she's barely knows
stay on your boat if you if she had let
him go she he could have been on the on
the wood Titanic to me Titanic and by
the way they've diagrammed it and he
could have fed on the plank and all that
but he had to die right that's just how
it is um this is why people idolize
Tupac so much this is why people had the
blind spot for tuba Tupac because he's
dead Tupac was a simp in real life he
was a gangster on the mic but he was a
simp in real life that's just what all
there was to it Jada Pinkett fell in
love with who she thought Tupac was
that's why she never got over him but
you know regarding the whole Jack and
the the whole Jack and Rose situation
yeah this woman was engaged to be
married had it great cheats on him
cheats on him with this kid if I'm Cal
I'm dude I'm I'm pretty Furious too like
I put my name out there I've I've
claimed you as my woman and you're
running around below decks dancing with
this with with this American kid who
came you know came from old Perry I'd be
feeling some type of way too but and
here's the thing I'm glad that he was I
know he was pissed off at DiCaprio's
character but but he shouldn't have been
he should have been pissed off at the
girl yeah that's all there is to it
there's so many guys who win their when
they find out their girl cheated on them
they misdirect their anger and they want
to do something to the guy uh my [__]
that's on your girl man like that's all
there is to well you shouldn't have hit
on her blah blah blah well your girl was
sending me choosing signals and nine
times out of ten the [__] always tells
the dudes they're [__] that they
don't have a boyfriend but the boyfriend
still gets mad that she cheated how am I
supposed to know if she tells me I don't
have a boyfriend what am I supposed to
do no I don't believe you let me see
your phone [__] out of here
yeah she was she was the first 304. oh
yes she was girls was the first home
yeah the first the first 304. yes and
her body count was two at that point two
was a lot she [__] uh Cal and then she
[__] Jack her body count was two well
she was a virgin when she met Cal
remember oh I I don't know oh yeah I've
only seen them in the movie well here's
the thing remember now so remember Jack
ended up dying right yeah Cal you know
obviously just didn't want to be with
her anymore she ended up in New York
City with a body count of two tell me
she didn't get around you're right rose
with the first hoe 1912 y'all yeah 1912.
do you think that oh what is your what's
your opinion on like like body count
should guys ask for a girl's body count
no no never gentlemen oh my God guys
listen to me should guys ask about her
exes like how what's the no don't ask
anything no you don't ask You observe
there are so many there are so many uh
relationship and dating experts that say
well if you want to know something about
a woman communicate with her ask her no
you want to know why because women
[__] lie they lie their [__] asses
off when you ask a girl about her body
count this tell that this it does two
things number one it makes you look
insecure as a man number one number two
she is going to lie it doesn't matter
what number she tells you whatever
number she tells you guys multiply it by
17 doesn't and that's around the answer
that's probably around yeah yeah I mean
you know give or take give or take give
or take a dozen in either direction you
know I mean you never know but yeah
don't ask women about their body counts
man because she's never going to tell
you the truth instead You observe Now
ladies if your guy asks you your body
count
keep an eye out you lie your ass off you
lie your ass off however there is a
caveat if if a girl is messing around a
dude if a girl is messing around with a
dude who asks her what her body count is
chances are he probably doesn't have a
game he probably doesn't have that much
experience with women because if you
have experience with women you know not
to ask them their body counts because
you know you know they're going to lie
however let's just say that there is one
gross outlier a guy who actually has a
little bit of game and knows his way
around a woman asks you the body count
question
tell him tell him seven lie your ass off
but the caveat is this the caveat is
this and this is why we tell guys to
observe
if you tell a guy that your body count
is seven but your body count is closer
to 77 you better act like your body
count is seven because let's just say
I'm dating a girl and in a moment of
weakness I get drunk what's your body
count no seven I'm like okay but then
she has a tattoo right she seems to know
a lot of she seems to know a lot of guys
she's very flirtatious when she's around
men she's attracted to she she gets
demonstrative have you ever uh um have
you ever heard of this before
like you can you can tell when a woman
is attracted to a man when she like if
you're at the grocery store right if a
woman's at a grocery store and she and
she finds herself being attracted to you
she will do things to get your attention
she'll be demonstrative maybe she'll
make a uh she'll make a motion so she'll
maybe maybe speak a little bit louder so
that you turn your head in that
direction this actually happened with me
and Devin when we went to Hawaii this
this happened with to me and Devin we
went to Hawaii so we're sitting there at
breakfast and we had only been seeing
each other for a few months and I know I
and I'm and we're right in front of each
other and I noticed that all of a sudden
she starts getting she starts talking
with her hands Devin never talks with
her hands because she's a low-key person
I instantly knew what was going on I
turn around and it looks like and it's
basically Thor sitting behind me you
want to know what I did you wanna know
what I did I said I got to the side just
like this so that they could see each
other I said well Devin like if you want
the guy's number you should just ask him
I mean we can trade up hotel rooms they
both turned a brilliant shade of magenta
and Devin never flirted with another man
in front of me since then do you think
she was doing that intentionally oh
absolutely one thousand percent oh wow
oh you better believe it you better
believe it again look dude like because
in my head like I just I'm a big like I
give people like the benefit of the
doubt no yeah yeah all right yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're you're I'm just like oh
she's just talking with her hands no she
was talking with her hands to become and
the reason I knew that is because I'll
be in Vegas at a corner store uh you
know a casino whatever the case may be
and I'll hear a woman talking loudly and
I'm looking around and I'm like oh well
who the hell is that after a while I
started figuring out oh she's giving me
indirect using signals I go over there
and approach they do not like break up
with her over that uh we were not
committed to each other yet she was
still in the training process oh okay
yeah was just curious which of you would
advise a guy to break up with a girl
over that if they were together no well
it depends on how far along it is in the
relationship and how serious it is so
this was there this was during the
training process we'd been seeing each
other I thought she responded well well
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean guys have to
understand when when when when you're
training a woman for a relationship
there's going to be a learning curve
she's not going to get it right all the
time and Devin she was 39 years old she
had just come out of a 20-year marriage
which which by the way was one of the
reasons I actually took her a little bit
more seriously is because she had
relationship skills she was in a
marriage for 20 years but by the same
token she had been divorced for six
months and was doing all the things that
divorce says that are attractive do when
they get divorced and so I had to train
a lot of those bad habits out of her
which included indirectly flirting with
men in my presence so as like from the
woman's point of view what like bad
habits can we get rid of to like make up
make us more marriageable to the men
today
so to I'll re-est the question for you
what are the types of things you should
do and not do right to not set off a
guy's alarm Bells okay right uh first of
all first of all stay off your phone
stay off your phone that's what I would
do second thing I would do and if you
really like the guy delete your
Instagram delete your Instagram stay off
your phone
um go over to his house a lot uh be
around him a lot if you have any
lingering X's block all their numbers
you know what Devin did what Devin did
when I told her all right she was like
hey look I want to be with you blah blah
all right well this is the training
process she changed her phone number
she changed the phone yeah she dude she
changed her phone number changed her she
had an Android went to Apple changed her
phone number so she cut off all
communication with all with any and all
X's flings whatever the case may be it
almost sounds nice I should change my
number I was thinking about this that is
probably a good idea I was like then I
could just limit because now you know
people come back they start hitting me
up for things get on the channel you
know it's like I have too many people
that have my number anyway well well
listen listen listen we we laugh and we
chuckle but let's just let's just say
for the sake of argument there was a guy
that you were interested in and maybe he
was interested in you if you were to
change your phone number and you tell
him why you did it that would make an
impression on him of that I am certain
what do you guys think in the back if a
girl came up to you and was like I
changed my number for you
yeah if you want look dude I believe you
I'm just like huh I never would have
even thought of that yeah that makes
that makes and I didn't even think of
that Devin did that on her own wow dude
she texted me from another number I was
like oh okay this one might actually
have a chance and the rest is history
were you like were you playing the field
before that oh yeah yeah I was dude
during the training process there were
two actually so when we first met I was
messing around with two other girls when
Devin and I got a little more serious
with the training she was actually in
competition with a girl almost half her
age I was dating a she out competed a
girl half her age she literally she did
she did this girl was 20. so I met this
so This Girl's name was Chrissy and uh I
had I dated her dated her on and off
since she was 19. this is funny I met
Chrissy three weeks after her po three
weeks after her post-op for her boob job
and this girl was a smoke show hard ten
beautiful Mexican girl beautiful
symmetry beautiful ass I mean dude like
she was a dude perfect body knew how to
stay in shape but she was as dumb as a
[__] tire she was as dumb as a tire
and and she could not cook I actually I
actually thought that maybe I could
teach her to cook so I paid 350 for her
to take cooking classes and it didn't
help anyway fast forward fast forward
fast forward and I Meet Devin I've been
dating Chrissy when I started dating
Devin and the little by little uh Devin
began to separate herself like she began
to separate herself and and when she
started sending me food when I was TR
she would send me food to where I was
traveling she would cook and send me
food I was like okay this is quite
something but the thing that won me over
one of the many things that Devin did
that won me over the quickest was she
installed cameras in her apartment so
that I could see not that I ever checked
and was spying on her but she she gave
me access to her alarm system she put a
key logger on her phone and I was like
wow this woman really is serious she
really was serious so ladies if if
there's a guy you really like this so
there's a guy like I should I should I
put cameras on my apartment listen wow
listen listen we laugh and we chuckle
but if we know how women are Pearl we
know what women are if they're if
they're not and if if and I'm not gonna
and I'm not telling you guys to work
quite well if you if you're gonna be
with me you need to have cameras in your
house no but if you are a woman and you
really want to show a guy that you
really want to be with him yeah
sometimes you need to go to those
extremes because because here's the
thing listen and I'm open because
there's a thing the kind the type of guy
that you would like yeah he knows he
knows how women are you know you
understand what I mean like and so there
is and so to to to assuage any lingering
doubt as to what you may or may not be
up to do as much as you possibly can to
be as transparent as humanly possible
and I promise you he will tell you no
one has ever done that for me before and
that's exactly what I told Devin
so how okay so we last time we talked
about how it like the red pill your red
pilling story
um so that that's a long one so I'm
gonna tell you guys if you want to see
yeah got the other video
last podcast
but what so how long have you been
making content for
um I've been on YouTube since 17. okay
but I've been writing in the red pill
since 14. since 14. so I've been in the
community for almost 10 years how how
have your views evolved from when how
have your views evolved since when you
first started and how has the community
evolved that is a very good question so
um
wow I have never been asked that before
um My Views My Views some of my views
have changed I suppose a little bit
um
if any if anything I'm more sure of what
the red pill teaches now okay than I was
back then
um there might be some surface level
there might be some surface level uh you
know operational you know in terms of
your day-to-day activities how you run
your relationship Etc et cetera that I
made that I may or may not have changed
because you know because of my age and
you know and evolving and all that but
other than that I'm just basically I'm
doubling down okay yeah and how is the
community evolved so it started so
because I understand it started in the
forums yeah yeah the red pill Blended
yeah let's let's go to the very
beginning yeah yeah all right yeah so
the red pill the red pill really
actually for viewers that don't know
what is the red pill okay so the red
pill is the reason why we call it the
red pill
um it's sort of uh uh sort of an analogy
the movie The Matrix you know Morpheus
offers Neo the blue pill or the red pill
if you take the blue pill you go back
you know you go back to dream world if
you take the red pill it's the truth
it's ugly and it's uncomfortable but
it's the truth Neil takes the red pill
and he learns that you know humans are
grown and you know copper top and all
that good stuff well that's really what
the red pill Community is the red pill
is the answer to feminism the red pill
is the red pill really is the answer to
the reason why relationships are so
[__] up that's really what it is
um and when you talk to people who are
not red pill aware you you know it
immediately right like you'll be anytime
you're in a group of friends and you're
talking about relationships one idiot
always says well the key to good
relationships is communication everybody
in their [__] grandmother says that
it's [__] [__] communication is
key but non-verbal communication is the
communication that that is what I'm
talking about but the red pill gives men
the red pill tells men the truth about
women sexual Dynamics and Inter
interpersonal Dynamics between women and
men not and it's not this Hocus Pocus
feminist inspired you know men and women
are equal no it's a very traditional
view but it has to be updated to deal
with modern women the way they are can I
have an example let's throw the people
at home oh yeah yeah so so for example
um if if you take a girl out on a date
way back in the day you know it will
show up with flowers no don't do that if
you show up with flowers a girl is going
to think you're a simp
um also if if uh you're supposed to take
a girl out on a first date uh take her
to a restaurant well we certainly don't
do that now right and the reason for
that is because of the the the what do
they call those foodie calls right so
what if um what if if he feels like this
is a quality woman what do you what do
you tell them so if a guy feels like
this is okay okay what if he's observed
that this is a quality woman what would
he have to observe for her um maybe he
knows her family
is that different I'm just curious oh so
okay maybe maybe it's a girl that he's
known in the community he's known her
for a while he knows she's she's not a
hoe yeah yeah that's a girl that's a
girl you take too you could take I'm
just curious if it's always or if
there's ever no that's a good caveat
I've never thought of it that way yeah
and those girls are rare but they are
out there so yeah if if there's a girl
that you've grown up with and you know
her family good family strong father
good family values and you know that
she's not the Town Bicycle yeah take her
because here's the thing if you don't
take her to dinner then her dad is going
to be feeling some type of way right
yeah but the whole idea is like it's a
risk like that's how I feel like the red
pill is more of a response to the way
women are yeah so like a lot of people
get mad when they say to spin plates
spin plates but it's like we like men
that spin plate yes right women like men
with experience yeah we don't like the
men that treat us like princesses right
in general right I don't know why women
don't like men who treat them actually
here let me let me let me check that
women don't like men who treat them like
princesses for doing nothing but
existing okay that's why we'll take a
girl out on an expensive date for for
the very first date yeah she'll say
thank you but she loses attraction for
you because she didn't do anything to
earn that 300 dinner date except for
just show up it is literally the same
thing as a girl sleeping with a guy on
the first date that's the that's the way
women the way the way we view women who
sleep with us on the first date we're
never going to commit to her well [__]
her for a while but then when something
else new comes along we're out the door
because if she sleeps with me how many
other guys has she's done it with right
it's the same thing with women women say
okay he took me out on this nice date
I'm never going to take him seriously
I'm never going to have sex with him but
I'll keep him around for a while until
the guy I actually want to have sex with
comes along it is literally the same
thing you are giving a woman something
that she has not earned and when and
women know what they deserve they know
it's not that they're it's not that it's
not this whole self-love type of deal
but especially hoes they know they're
not they know 500 dinner so it's
interesting because it's like you also
hear from the manosphere a woman that
makes you wait is never worth the wait a
hoe that makes you wait is never worth
the wait yeah that's here here's the
deal man as far as that and that's I
think that's something that Rolo yeah I
mean I've heard different variations
from it where they're like yeah if she
doesn't sleep with you kick her out and
call another girl I've heard that I
heard that and I'm like it's just a
little bit contradictory sometimes this
is like this is
um
this is what what they'll say I I
understand like where you guys are
coming from because it's an adaptation
to the hose in the market that's exactly
right right so I understand where
they're coming from but like a criticism
I hear like of the red pill constantly
is that
it's it's like you're telling the men to
sleep with all these girls but the girls
but while you're also complaining about
the body counts hey guess what
um
nobody's putting a gun to their head yes
right now we're not putting we're not
putting the gun to these hoes you know
what I mean like dude girls girls are
people are going girls are like get
naked in front of Drake and be like oh
no exactly yeah exactly it's
it's ridiculous yeah I dude I remember I
had a good uh a good friend
um and we used to say all the time we
tell girls look man look look look look
look if you want to be in a relationship
with me you need to protect yourself
from me I'm going to try to [__] you
because you're attractive and that's
just what men do but if you want me to
take you seriously you need to resist
that as you need to resist that for as
long as you can and the way I see it is
this so a girl goes to see a guy right
he kicks her out because he doesn't want
to sleep because she doesn't want to
sleep with him she's feeling some type
of way well isn't the purpose to be in a
relationship so if you're mad that he
kicked you out for not having sex then
you don't want to be with that guy
anyway because you want the relationship
right that's the same thing
now
I agree I was just like that's just what
I always hear from
um yeah it's almost like they like to
say well you guys create the women you
complain about that may be true but
nobody's forcing anybody to do anything
yeah I'm just a big believer everything
in life is your own fault if guys treat
you like you're a hoe like that's that's
probably you probably did something to
indicate that yes absolutely called
hotels
Tendencies
um
so tell me more about how the space has
evolved over time so it started with the
Forum No it started before that it
started with the the Neil Strauss book
uh the game and from the game then
started the start of the forums the so
Suave Forum after the forums it sort of
evolved into Pua the pickup the pickup
artist Community mystery uh these are
the people that don't know the forums
would you name which ones the only ones
that I'm aware of are uh roycie and uh
roycie and so Suave that was that was
the main one there were other forums
that were smaller but so Suave that's
where Rollo cut his teeth that's when
people are like oh you should write a
book
um so so from the forums now people are
taking the information from the forums
and from the book The Game by Neil
Strauss and they started applying it in
real life that's when we started getting
videos pickup technique techniques etc
etc then then after that then we started
having blogs this is Return Of Kings the
rational male illimitable man other
forms other blogs
um The Evolution the evolution from
there was YouTube uh YouTube really it
really put pickup game and and the red
pill and right I would say that right
around the time right around the time
the blog the blog started coming out
that's when the term manosphere was
starting to be the moniker nobody called
the manosphere back in 2002 not even
when the puas were out on the scene but
when when when blog but when blogs and
stories and other articles started
started coming up oh that's the red pill
that's the matosphere et cetera et
cetera
um so is there a difference between the
red pill and the manosphere that's the
same thing it's the same thing yeah yeah
um and so so after so after the YouTube
Evolution then came the self-improvement
evolution
um a lot of guys were starting to grow
up right okay you know you know I've
I've chased women I've gotten all the
[__] I can but you know we want we
wanted guys to be well-rounded because
of course they were getting you know a
bunch of backlash just like you said oh
you guys create the women you complained
about so now guys are talking about
self-improvement get your body right get
your finances right and women will make
themselves available to you
um from there there was there was one
more Evolution and that was
relationships a lot of the guys who were
the pickup artists wrote for Return Of
Kings we grew out of that stage and we
found ourselves in relationships and
that's where we are now where where does
mgtow fall in so mgtow is one of a few
factions are they under the manosphere
would you yeah that's under that that's
under that's under the manuscript
yeah there's a red pill mgtow black pill
there's self-improvement there you go
tell them what
um black pill is
so the one of the stages of the red pill
when a guy finds the red pill it's
called Uh the anger phase when when you
when when things start to make sense
when when you read this stuff and you're
like oh my God you start can I have can
I have an example of something that
would yeah yeah when you like when you
read something and you think of like um
um um let me think so let's say somebody
writes a story or an article about his
experience with his girlfriend or
something like that and
um let's just say yeah you know I found
out my my girlfriend and my wife was
cheating on me because she was working
late and she told me X Y and Z or she
was going out for girls nights out and
or going out for girl for girls Vegas
trips or going on work trips and I found
out that she was having an affair with
her boss right a guy will see that and
he'll be like you know what so that's
what my wife was doing when she was
going to these conferences that's what
my wife was doing when she was going on
these these these supposed girl strips
that's what my wife was doing when she
said she was visiting family right so
they get mad because they start thinking
about all of their past relationships
and the things that we talk about
they're like oh my God not only that
they get upset because they feel that
they've been lied to
and to be honest with you I don't think
however they've been lied to I don't
think they've been lied to
um I think they were just given the
wrong information
um we say all the time never take
relationship advice from your mother
never take relationship advice from
women guys it's I agree I agree don't
take relationship that I told them on
the last part I was just and I'm like
like how would I know how to vet a woman
like you guys even the average guy has
like that his vet more women than I have
of course like absolutely yeah
absolutely man yeah so when your mother
tells you okay I'll give my uh an
example with my mother
um my mother would give me all of the
same information you have to treat her
well cherish her bring her flowers blah
blah blah blah my mother wasn't lying to
me right but she wasn't giving me the
right information we were given we
weren't given the right tools to be
successful with women back when I was
married I was calling my mom mom why is
my why is my wife not [__] me you
have to cherish her you have to make her
feel special that did nothing it made it
worse and so guys get angry about out
that stuff but the black pill is when
guys stay in the anger stage because
after the anger stage which most people
go through you you learn acceptance and
then adaptation and then you start
living the red pill life and congruence
do you do you feel like there's some
valid criticism when they say that the
red pill is filled with in cells and
angry men yeah oh yeah there's
definitely yeah that's definitely valid
absolutely dude when you see what's
happening with you see what's happening
with Andrew Tate all of the hashtag me
too false rape accusations I mean and
going back to the mgtows because that's
the the black pill is kind of a
derivative of mgtows but um I I used to
be hard on those guys because they're
like no I'm going my way I'm not messing
with women I used to roast those guys
but the more dude the more time goes by
the more empathetic I am and I'm like
Hey look it's not what I would do but I
can't say I blame you guys for walking
away from women why why don't you blame
them like what what made your opinion
change just
yeah the false accusations
um I don't know if you've ever heard of
Emma sulkowitz the The Mattress girl she
claimed that she she was raped on her
futon mattress in college I yeah I've
heard of that story roughly roughly tell
them tell them for the people I know it
like roughly sorry so the girl claims
she was raped on her on her mattress but
they recovered text messages of her
texting and and it was a one night stand
and the guy curb her after that she felt
some type of way and she said she and
she said she was raped it was found out
that and she wanted him expelled it was
found out that that that it wasn't
really rape and he wasn't charged but in
order to make a stand she carried her
her futon mattress around campus until
he was expelled that was her senior
thesis that kind of stuff happened then
the Jackie Coakley uh stuff happened at
the University of West Virginia that was
that was nothing but [__] then then
athletes and rappers started getting
accusations and they're all being shot
down Time After Time After Time then the
hashtag metoo movement happened right
after that and so that's that's really
what's making men walk away it's like
dude if if you even mess with women
you're not only like you're risking your
life you're risking your freedom and
guys are not trying to go to jail for
trying to holler at a [__] why why do
you think that's so common what do I
think what's so common like false
accusations because there's no
repercussions for false accusers that's
why that's why this is why women
continue to make false accusations
because they're not being punished for
making false accusations and Andrew Tate
uh I was on the I was on fresh and fit
and Myron found video of the girls who
claimed that they were raped by Andrew
Tate after the time that they said that
he was rape dancing and twerking what
yes you gotta dude you gotta watch that
like dude we dispelled all of that bit
by bit by bit it's it's all a hit job
this is Andrew Tate top G this guy
doesn't he doesn't have to rape anybody
he's got dude he's got girls lined up
around the block trying to get into his
Mansion there is no there is no reason
for him to forcibly have sex with
another woman when women want to do it
already anytime a woman accuses a rapper
or an athlete or a public figure of rape
it really I'm not going to say that none
of them are true because there's the
Darren Sharper situation that was really
bad uh there was Kellen Winslow etc etc
but a lot of these like a good amount of
these are false so you mean to tell and
it's funny the story is All the Same we
say well why didn't you go to the cops
well because I was ashamed oh wait so
let me get this straight you didn't want
to go to the cops but you're comfortable
with sharing your your heroing with your
27 000 Twitter followers I agree that
was the one thing that red pilled me
doing the show oh really well yeah
because I I just generally thought when
women like said things like that serious
that it was true yeah right and
um the more and more girls that I had on
the show
um that they would they would say
through these stories
I would immediately believe them but
then someone a comment said ask them did
they go to the police every time they
bring that up and I was thinking good
question and I was just shocked by how
many women said no that's right and I
was just thinking wow like you guys are
comfortable to enough to go on my
podcast and talk about it here we go um
but you're not comfortable enough to
talk about or to go to the police second
thing that I didn't understand was that
or that I didn't realize was abusive
relationship how women will say they
were abusive but they don't talk about
that they were hitting him right and
often instigated and like they'll say oh
there was bruises on my arms but but
like sometimes people in the comments
would just say stuff and they'd be like
well ask her was he holding her down
there you go and I was just thinking
wow like good question good these are
good questions and it's like kind of
awkward like you don't want to question
someone on this stuff but but that's but
what I noticed is that that people that
that actually happened to have no
problem answering questions right and
here's another they have no problem
answering questions but they're not
going to do it on camera because if they
really were raped or abused they don't
like dude if a woman truly is raped
she's not gonna go and tell people about
it have you ever have you ever watched a
woman on the stand testifying against
her attacker dude they break down man
they break down she doesn't want to
relive it she doesn't want to face him
again yet here you are on a podcast well
he raped me he abused me it's it and
again just like you said uh you know you
like you usually take girls at face
value but the fact that we don't want to
question them because you know we find
it offensive women know this and that's
why when you ask them questions about it
that leads them to to believe that maybe
you don't believe what they're saying
that's when they oh my God I can't
believe it no no you don't believe what
I'm saying this half happened to me all
you have to do is ask all you have to do
is just ask questions and just continue
to ask questions and eventually and it
does not take you long to come to the
conclusion that they're just lying
yeah and that was one thing about Kevin
Samuels he was so good he was so good at
just getting I just saw a clip of him
the other day where he figured out that
a girl was lying about a proposal yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I'm like how did he
figure that out like he was like ask
questions he was like what were you
eating what was that here we go and I'm
just like I would never I would have
just been like yeah okay nice proposal
yeah I mean it's I think well here's the
reason why he knew she was lying because
he was the restaurant owner she says
well restaurant owner proposed to me
right and the girl I I gotta find the
video
but the the woman had a smoke detector
in the background basically she was
basically she was a ratchet right and if
you're a ratchet restaurant restaurant
owners aren't proposing to you so he
knew that was cap off from the start and
he didn't accuse her of lying all he did
was ask questions and remember when she
tried to she tried to give all this
background information Kevin no no no
just just skip all that give me the
details what did you eat blah blah blah
blah and guess what she ended up hanging
up the phone because she knew she was
caught
do you think that the dating Market is
getting worse or better oh
yeah it's getting worse I I think so too
it is and I don't and I don't say that
in like I'm happy no and I have the
whole people are like do you think the
wife school will work and I'm like well
for a couple people it couldn't hurt
yeah but I'm like do do I think that by
and large we're gonna have less women on
only fans hell no we can hope I could
sell you a dream yeah but I'm like do I
do I see it getting better by and large
I think eventually I mean everything is
cyclical right right the world goes
right now it's a little warm right there
was there was also an ice age at one
point in time right
um you know things were I'll use I'll
use the presidential cycle as sort of an
analogy for this Jimmy Carter was he was
he was a great man right everybody
remembers him for the gas lines right so
they corrected to Ronald Reagan okay
Ronald Reagan was extremely Conservative
then then his uh his Vice President
George H.W bush was then elected so now
we've got 12 years of Republicans in
office then Bill Clinton came along that
was a bit of an over correction Bill
Clinton was in office for eight years
then they corrected even more to George
W bush had him for eight years then we
way over corrected to Barack Obama had
him in office for eight years then we
ran it off the road with Donald Trump
you understand what I mean and and I
support Trump by the way I'm team Trump
but you understand how it's all cyclical
well it's the same thing with the dating
Market I think at some point it is going
you know conservative values you know
you know conventional masculinity to
traditional femininity it is going to
come back I just don't think it's going
to happen in my I don't think it's going
to happen in my lifetime and I know that
sounds cynical but just like you said
man I mean can you really see 10 years
from now there being less girls on only
fans no I'm like we could we could sell
a dream but it's like I don't I'm just
being real well here's the thing man
this this is why this is why I do what I
do is just to help guys maybe have a
Fighter's chance and maybe trying to
have a relationship with a woman that
you honestly love and can possibly trust
but if I'm being honest I mean if if my
brother said Donovan what's the best
thing for me to do if I want a wife and
kids I would be like dude you got to go
overseas and stay there you cannot have
you cannot have a wife and children in
the west can't have it here can't have
it in England can't have it in Australia
you gotta go overseas man
what so you were one of the first
content creators to bring women in the
space yeah
um how are you happy that you did
absolutely 100 and tell me why well
because and what are what were your
major concerns about bringing women into
the space yeah yeah yeah yeah so my
concerns about bringing women into the
space before is I it was it was almost
like intent okay is this woman creating
content just for attention on herself
because throughout throughout the red
pill Journey we've had women sniffing
around here and there they'll follow us
on Twitter they'll make Twitter posts
they'll call into shows but
but women didn't really start you know
creating content until just recently but
the re the reason I did it is because I
thought it was necessary
um I think that women have access to
certain people's eyeballs and ears that
men don't this is another reason why you
blown up so quickly because they can't
call you a misogynist because you're a
woman you can say thing you can say
things that I can't yeah and that's why
I always want to try to like give credit
where credit's due to the content
creators that I feel like are smarter
than me you know that have been doing
this for a while like I never want to
like take credit for you know what I'm
saying so I just wanted to know like
what is the best way that I can like
give
I'm just trying to help the space yeah
and I'm just trying to figure out like
the best way to do that moving forward
yeah so
um in the future
um you'll catch a lot less heat if you
say something that you heard another
content creator say right after say just
say shout out like even even though I do
it
um uh with uh with what we said about
what was the thing that we said it was
um
it was something that Rolo said but if
if you say something and you know you
heard it from me yeah blah blah blah
shout out roller tomasi or women never
go women women uh women grow old but
they never grow up shout out Donovan
sharp
um the reason why body count matters is
because a paternity shout out Rolla
tomasi
um I never you know never uh you know
the more the more money a woman makes
the more doors close the more money a
man makes the more doors open shout out
Myron Gaines that's that's the that is
the best way to let people know hey I
have this knowledge but this these are
the guys that that said it before me
yeah because
um I don't know sometimes I feel like
but you know how it's I don't know I'm
just really trying to like help the guys
in the space and I never want to take
credit for like ideas that aren't you
know that they came up with and I'm
always trying to be as accurate as
possible
um so I don't know I'm trying to like
improve and get better and but it's like
this all came really fast so I'm not I'm
not gonna be perfect along the way so of
course not but I always I always like I
want to give credit to you you know you
were one of the first people to help me
it's not a big deal man I I've never had
a problem helping people because like I
mean I've lived a great life man um I've
made a lot of mistakes trust and believe
but like dude the red pill has changed
my life it's it's changed my life
socially financially dude I've got all
the dude I've got all the money I've got
all the cars I've got all the toys and
so you know the message for me the
message everybody wins it the message
that gets out there it doesn't matter
whether it's me you Myron whoever yeah
as long as people see it that that's to
me that's all that matters it's changed
my life too honestly yeah I mean it's
it's completely switched my world view
on things like I never thought about how
men are so discriminated against in
society yeah like because from the
women's point of view right I I
understand the way of the women they're
saying I gave this man like I mean which
it's it's off obviously these men are
only the top 20 but like as women we
don't know we're going for the top 20 30
like we just think oh this guy's cute
and not like we're not or that there's
always going to be somebody else yeah
yeah this is so and then we'll spend or
not me particularly but the common
stories will spend men in order to get
married and they're trying to offset the
risk of marriage yes so what they'll do
is in order to do that they will date a
girl for like five years seven years so
like now it's almost like living
together is the new early marriage and
we'll almost get married this frustrates
the women because we're giving up our
youth yes and that's why when Kevin
Samuels was talking about how like mad
like high value men marry in six months
or less or whatever I don't know if I
necessarily agree I never agreed with
that because because I think that men
are logical and they're trying to offset
the risk and so what they'll do is
they'll date a girl for like ever but
the girls are mad because they think if
he loved me he would marry me and I
don't think that's necessarily true I
just think men are logical I think you
can get a lot of men to marry you like I
I don't it's not impossible but I'm
saying like a lot of times you'll have
to sacrifice more of your youth up front
yeah and that's the
and so it made me understand men a lot
better because it's like
um even you know my brother's getting
married and yeah he's engaged but he
dated the girl for like five years three
four I don't even he's been dating with
her first tell him uh tell him not uh
let's talk about this girl is she is she
quality or no she's great she's uh it's
funny my brothers my brothers somehow
get the met the women that like the red
pill like wants so like but it's like
they don't know anything so like my one
brother's dating a girl it's a virgin or
like was you know
not anymore yeah yeah and my other
brother like the the girl he's dating is
an engineer and she went to cooking
school for fun
[Music]
she cooks she cleans he didn't even ask
her to do any of this stuff he was just
like oh that's cool
decide to go to cooking school yeah and
I'm like this is like the guys that like
would love that with their girlfriend
yeah she just did it she's great
um and so I'm I mean you know you never
really know with women right so I I
always like um coach Greg Adams that
like women are a roll of the dice yes
and I thought that was a great analogy
because you'll never really know it's a
risk but that's why we take the time to
observe and bet but so um like she was
more laid back about it but another
woman might think that he doesn't love
her right but it's like that's not it he
just wants to offset the freaking risk
and he's seeing his uncle his father get
screwed over thank you with these with
these seemingly good women that's right
and they'll like they'll say oh her
entire personality changed after the
second kid there you go and it's like a
lot of times as women I just think we
can benefit from understanding men
better yeah absolutely yeah
um and we could be better wives
girlfriends like I say all the time
unfortunately here in 2023 girlfriends
are better than wives man you say it all
the time women are paid to leave there
yes yeah this is why and again and this
is why I will never ever marry Devin uh
legally right if I I mean who knows I
might decide to marry her if I do it
we're leaving the state and the
government out of it we'll have you know
we'll we'll have the ceremony we'll have
the whole that'd be the flower girl yeah
I've always wanted to be a flower girl I
was always passed up because I was a fat
kid
we will definitely if we do dude we'll
make it a we'll make it a really nice
ceremony we'll invite all you guys we'll
invite you Pro you Ali Janelle
um uh Tallulah like we'll really make it
like a red pill wedding type yeah dude
we'll have the cake and the ice cream
we'll have the dance and all that good
stuff but we're not signing papers yeah
and I think that is that and real quick
before you go on and a lot of you might
be thinking yeah there's common law
marriage it's no accident that that uh
that Devin and I live in a state where
there's no common law marriage and we're
looking to purchase a property where
there is no common law marriage so you
guys can miss me with that yeah and I
think that's like a fair I I mean I
don't even want to say fair because the
women always get the better end of the
stick but it's a more fair deal yes like
like that's at least a compromise where
and but it's like if you told that told
that to the average woman yeah she
thinks you don't love her right right
but that's not it and
um and then like the friends will get in
the air well if he really loved you and
then like to us it's embarrassing to our
friends of course because oh Sally down
the street got married her blue pill man
did this right yeah Sally's husband
doesn't know any better right yeah and
that's the and that's the thing here's
the thing though the cheat code to that
is private marriage like like like
listen players out here if you if you're
a high value guy and you're with a woman
who appears to be the real deal
you can you can marry her just don't do
it legally well what about kids because
there's no way it doesn't seem like even
talking to to lead attorney he was he
said you know I'm not even afraid of
marriage I'm afraid of a child yeah
that's exactly because it seems like
there's no way around that with the kids
yeah like you're really not gonna get
custody no you're not yeah that's
um yeah that's that's the only that's
the only thing that's the only risk that
a man has you can you know you can use
dick detention
um or I mean dick discipline use condoms
blah blah blah blah and in in children
are the children are the ultimate
equalizer I am a I have made dude I have
I have [__] up my life in so many ways
man I oh my God I am dude I'm a
four-time convicted felon I've been
arrested 30 some 30 some odd times I was
dude I was I'm I'm still kind of a
hothead but the reason but the reason
why the reason why I I've retired my two
sisters and I was able to buy my
girlfriend in a Range Rover for her
birthday is because I did not have any
children Pearl I made all the mistakes
all of them the one mistake I did not
make was having children children that
is the one thing that can bring a man to
his knees so in terms of if you want a
wife and kids I can help you with the
wife part just don't marry her legally
as far as the children's stuff you're on
your own there but even still you could
actually use a cheat code uh you could
use a surrogate
wait what you could use it like let's
let's just let but you're gonna have to
your girl is gonna have to be okay with
this if the only way and I this is not
going to be feasible because women want
their own children but the only way I
can't even think of I could not agree
with that yeah right exactly but you see
how but do you see how [__] up the
laws are that you have to you have to
consider using a surrogate and not
having an actual biological child with
the woman you want to be with so it's I
don't have an answer for the kids I got
an answer for the marriage but as far as
kids are concerned you're on your own
there man yeah that's that's what lead
was saying I was like Wow because when
he said he said on this podcast he said
those kids aren't yours nope and he's
like do you know how many kids like
they're they're mother turned the kid
against the father and I I know people
that person like like you hear it all
the time man all the time where the
mothers will just be in their ear they
don't like their dad and the dad wanted
to be there the whole time it happened
to freaking Kanye yes yes
he loved his mom he loved his mother man
and it's like why is that about like us
as women like why are we so spiteful
that's just women is that yeah it's just
women and women and here's another thing
women think they own their children so
much so that they actually terminate the
pregnancy before their my body my choice
you don't own your children well
apparently women think they do so if
they have that kind of ownership what
makes you think they're not gonna have
the same kind of ownership if they
actually carry the birth the term right
wow
if you want to have and and I understand
a lot of men have a strong biological
desire to have children to have a legacy
I get that and that that's the one
unfortunately unfortunately that
biological desire that's the one that is
the one thing that that gets men tripped
up I am very fortunate I do not have the
biological desire to have children and
I'm gonna ask you ever regret not having
kids no no I for whatever reason I don't
I'm not special or different I've just
never wanted kids man I just and I dude
I love my nieces and nephews when they
were babies I loved having around man
Uncle Donovan's always coming around
with the jelly beans in the in the
Mountain Dew and then leaving with my
sister but I just I just never had that
desire and a lot of people ask me
a lot of people ask me well you know
what what about the what about the
Legacy thing well I'm leaving my legacy
with what I do with my content because
Years After I'm dead and gone people
will always remember the name Donovan
sharp for better or worse and that to me
is my legacy so I don't have a strong I
don't have a strong desire because most
people are Anonymous right you and I we
we are we are very fortunate or we're in
a very unique position to the point how
can I put this our situations are very
unique because more people know of and
or about us than people we actually know
personally
99.9 of people on Earth can't say that
everyone that a person knows also knows
them but I mean on the yacht party dude
that yeah dude there were 300 people on
that yacht including a hundred and
something women and almost all of them
recognize me that is I can't even tell
you how incredibly surreal that is
that that fuels my desire not to have
kids because my legacy said I'm good
how common do you think it is so we
always talk about sexless marriages we
talk about men not getting access to
their children
um we talk about men getting screwed
over and divorced
how common is that so I it's like if 10
men get married how many get screwed
over you know I don't know but I do know
this it happens enough I mean it's
common it's common enough for the red
pill Community to have been created
right A lot of people like Ruslan yeah
they'll actually oh that never ever
happens in statistics no no look look
I'm not look I'm not a statistical guy I
don't know stats I'm sure that there are
some stats out there that are more or
less accurate than others but if it
happens enough for P for if it happens
and like we could go outside right now
and we could you could ask a bunch of
people hey is getting married a a great
proposition for men you know there's
going to be a certain percentage that
says no at random we could fly to
Minnesota tomorrow same thing I don't
know what the percentages are I don't
know how out of how you know out of 10
or out of 100 but enough men get screwed
over that a lot of men are walking away
so that and to me that's that's enough
that's enough
do you think because another criticism
that I got a certain podcast what kind
of men are walking away but I've I found
what do you mean like they'll this is
what they'll say they'll say like it's
it's the the guys that men that women
don't want anyway do you think yeah
that's true uh yeah well yeah that's
that's true to a degree something about
a criticism about mgtows they say you're
not men going your own way your own way
you were sent your own way in a lot of
cases that is true and I don't have
anything against the mgtow guys anymore
but there there are certain people who
who were never really and just because
you're not good with women does not mean
you're a failure as a man or a human
being because being good with women
today requires us to do and be to study
it well not only that in order to be see
in order to be successful if women back
in 1950 we just used our instincts be
nice to her open the door for her but
today we have to go against our
biological instinct to take care of a
woman that we actually like in order to
get her to respect us us and so a lot of
guys just are not willing to do that so
do you think women change like okay do
you think women have always been that
way yes but that like there just was
consequences for being that way or do
you think women changed no women have
not like women have always liked the bad
boy women have dude women have always
loved the Bad Boys women have always
loved the Bad Boys
um
you ever seen the movie 310 from Yuma
I'm not a big movie person okay it's a
it's an awesome movie uh Russell Crowe
oh wait give me a second no Christian
yeah Christian Bale Russell Crowe long
story short Russell Crowe is this he's
this Billy badass character and
Christian Bale is this guy with a wife
and a family well Russell Crowe's
character is like on the run from the
law and Christian Bale's character has
to get him on the train 310 to Yuma
Russell Crowe's character you know walks
into the home hi Kristen Bell's wife was
visibly visibly aroused by him visibly
women have always been this way but
because of the because of the
consequences the way things were
structured women dads were involved
there you go yes there you go every once
in a while one would slip through and
you know have a little something with
the bad boys but by and large the women
stayed to themselves but you know with
the Advent of hormonal birth control
women could now sleep with the bad boys
and marry the good guys
what do you think of the criticism that
there aren't enough good men today
do you think that's true
do I think it's true that there aren't
enough good men today that that's just a
common criticism I get that the women
are bad because there aren't enough good
men there's not enough husbands
no that's not true that's not true I
will say this well here's the yeah I
don't I don't think that's true at all
but I will say this I think there are
less I think there are less good men out
there but the less the reason why
there's less good men is a response to
the women yeah exactly right man and
that's what and that's when I realized
watching the content I'm like gosh it is
our own faults exactly it is our own
fault it's incredible and they all they
do is complain about it and they don't
sleep with somebody else
well and then it's like it's that was
the biggest thing that I was taken away
from Kevin Samuels content it's like if
you are complaining about trash men it's
the men that you pick thank you you
picked him right and that's like I'm
just a big accountability person like
like I I have absolutely I've been in a
toxic relationship and even like during
that I I said this is my own fault like
because like you're like you're the
first woman my dad I was like crying to
my dad about something and I was just
like that like this I was like I'm sorry
Dad this is my fault I should have
listened to you this is my fault this is
my fault I'm like because that's just
how I look at life like you can either
if you don't if you view everything as
like the world then it's like you have
no control but if you look at it as like
your own fault then it's like you can
kind of move differently and make
different choices yep nobody put a gun
to your head to stay in that toxic
relationship yeah at the end of the day
it's always a choice it's always a
choice yeah
but
I love these conversations with you I
was like whenever we talk I'm like we
should it should just be a pod it should
be a podcast I mean it's to me it's I
remember one time I had a conversation
with Kevin and
um I was like I said Kevin this was like
during his rise I'm like yo how is it
that you always know exactly what to say
to these hoes like he says Donovan the
reason we're undefeated the reason I'm
undefeated is because the we tell the
truth yeah you can't like when you tell
the truth there's no rebuttal to that do
you ever sugarcoat things to like girls
no never no dude I've been on fresh and
fit 20 times I don't sugarcoat [__] I
don't sugarcoat [__] with my own woman
yeah I don't know matter of fact
um our uh oh God I'm calling her my
niece now Devin's niece Olivia
uh she's she's gonna turn 15 pretty soon
beautiful girl gorgeous girl she can
Dude literally can have any man she
wants I met her oh yes yeah dude when
she's a little girl dude she was as cute
as a button anyway
um
when she asks about stuff because now
she's starting to you know now she's you
know getting into boys and everything
when she asks me about stuff I tell her
what's up I tell her what's up and I
made a deal with her I said Olivia I
said if you stay a virgin if you stay a
virgin
uh until you graduate from high school I
will buy you a car I told her that I
said I will buy you a car and I said and
if you stay and I told her she doesn't
have the best home situation
um and but I think I I think we can pull
this off I told her I said when you turn
18 and you graduate if you um I said I
said I will let you live with us
dude you can live and stay with us until
you get married I told her that that's
the deal that I made with her I said you
stay if you're a virgin when you
graduate high school I'll buy you a car
and if you if if I don't want you to I
don't want you to be out there in the
world I said you can live with us for as
long as it takes for you to get married
that's what I told her and she asked me
why and I just broke it all down to her
and she was like wow is she receptive
you think yes of course yeah well well
you know when you tell a 14 year old you
know you're gonna buy her a car she's
going to be all in on that but but we
and Devin had to sit her down and have a
really tough conversation Devin says hey
look like it didn't exactly go that way
for me and here are the problems that it
caused and I think it I think it made an
impression on her that's that's my
biggest gripe with like the typical
Modern Woman is I don't like that they
lie to younger women oh my like it makes
me really mad because it's like critical
it's like what they're doing is when
they fail when you fail a test in school
what's the best thing that you could do
when you turn no no when you turn around
like if okay if I fail the test and I
Turn to You and I say okay oh like oh I
failed and you said oh me too you feel
better and that's what these wow and
that's what these older women are doing
to the younger women is they don't want
to be alone in their poor decisions
so they they Market their poor decisions
to the younger women so they're not
freaking alone not only that they're
also competing with the younger women
yeah older women are always jealous of
younger women because younger women are
doing what the older women used to do
but for reasons known only to the
Creator himself I have no idea have you
ever noticed that younger that older
women always lead younger women astray
but the older men were always trying to
help the young guys
older men are like give you better
advice than older women too oh well I
mean there's like same sex yeah yeah
even vice versa like well I don't know
like older women you don't take advice
but like grandmas like grandmas and old
aunts and uncles or old aunts they'll
break it down to you like they'll let
you know it depends if that girl is
happily married yeah it's like married
women are in a relationship this is how
this is this is interesting so my
brother my so I'm the oldest of five
three boys two girls
um and so my middle brother with an M uh
he's he's been married now for 12 years
two Kit dude oh my God my niece oh my
God I like she is the cutest she is the
cutest little thing anyway I love babies
it's kind of my thing anyway long time
ago he was dating these he was dating
these two women
and one of the one of the girl dude the
first woman he was dating beautiful drop
dead gorgeous girl man she was very
outgoing she was very you know she was
you know she was cool to be around she
was kind of the life of the party right
she would challenge my brother every
once in a while then he dated this other
girl she was attractive enough she was
kind of homely came from a better family
um her mother and father her mother and
father were professors at Penn State uh
but very you know very very homely very
very down to earth my brother was on my
brother my brother I think he said he
was confused about which woman to pick
which woman to go all in with my mother
told him to go with the girl that
challenges him go with the pretty girl
that challenges you my brother did the
opposite and married the other girl and
12 years later here they are it's
something about my brother knew and
understood that that that his wife was
that the woman he picked was the better
choice despite what my mother told him
my mom dude my mom is six years old men
are logical yes like I just think at the
end of the day like women we operate on
emotion yep so it's like if we see a
girl that oh we like her like she's fun
or whatever like well you know we might
give fun girls are bad for marriage I
say this all the time marry the
introvert man don't dude extroverted
girls now this isn't to say this isn't
to say that introverted girls don't
cheat but extroverted girls there's a
much higher chance of probability that
an extroverted girl with cheat will
cheat because she's getting more
attention from men as a natural
byproduct of her outgoing personality
again this isn't to say that introverted
girls you know never cheat matter of
fact if they do cheat you'll probably
never find out but the extroverted girl
is getting so much more attention
because she's the life of the party and
this is the thing like I feel like a lot
of times girls will be like not all but
it's like guys I like on a balance of
probability yes exactly like and I'm I'm
very extroverted and I was like on a
balance of probabilities like I I
totally understand where the guys are
coming from right yeah it's like they're
just looking for the girl with the
lowest risk men are logical
that's it and like you can't and like
girls will come back and say oh they're
misogynistic I'm like it's not
misogynistic guys are just like this is
how much sense men are just logical like
this is how guys think like what is the
lowest risk yes right the lower the the
and and nothing is guaranteed nothing is
guaranteed my mother my mother was a
virgin bride she ended up becoming an
epic in Epic oh I had oh my gosh I had a
friend in college where she her and
parents because it was funny I remember
like talking to her about like sleeping
around and I was just like I don't
really like want to do that like it's
just not because like I was a virgin at
the time right and so because and so um
what I told her was what she told me was
that she had ants and like moms that
were virgins on their wedding day but
wish they weren't what that's what I
said and they were still married but
they're like yeah like I wish or maybe
they got divorced I can't remember this
was so long ago but it was like either
they either got divorced and then like
slept around and like wished they had
and I came from Catholic school I was
like I've never heard of that like
someone that waited because everyone I
knew that again everyone I knew that
waited was like happy they waited once
again this is older women leading
younger women Australia yeah you doing
telling a younger woman man I I regret
being a virgin on my wedding day what is
that yeah but I think it's like Rolo
talks about the dynamic of the making up
for missing out
and that's why I say like you could have
the perfect girl and it's like like I I
think coach Greg Adams that's saying
like women are a role of the dice is
such a good saying because you could
have the perfect girl and she could like
like the versions of yesterday aren't
the virgins of today because the virgins
of today have social media and I still
feel like they missed out that's exactly
right so it's like you could just pick
your poison pick your that's why when
people are like oh what's your dating
advice where do I find the good girls
I'm like God only knows
it's like it's you pick your poison pick
a good bet pick one that seems low risk
man women do the best you can yeah men
and women haven't changed it's the
environment that's that's really what it
comes down to yeah women have always had
Endless Options back in 1923 they've
always had Endless Options the
difference between 1923 and 2023 is that
women are now aware of their Endless
Options I remember
pardon me I remember Andrew was telling
us the story he was in this he was I
mean him and his him and his buddies
drove to like the small village in
Romania and it was a really really small
town and he remember seeing like two
very very attractive women in this
coffee shop and he remembers thinking he
said he said wow are there actually hot
girls here that don't know they're hot
because they look modest but they were
very attractive
the first one had 500 000 Instagram
followers the second one had like 450
000 Instagram followers small village in
Romania half a million followers on
Instagram thirst trap pictures you can't
get away from it man do you think these
women will buy dogs and die alone yes or
do you think that there will always be
someone
I gave you the answer already oh so yes
yes here's the thing a lot of guys say
well women still win because there's
always going to be a guy there to be
with them a lot of people say Brittany
Renner okay she slept around but some
simp is going to wipe her up and that's
the point yes maybe women won't be alone
but they will not be happy if a woman
married I'll put it to you like this
roll it says this all the time oh women
would rather and they would never admit
this out loud but when a woman would
rather share an alpha with she'd rather
share an alpha with two or three other
women than have a beta all to herself
with nothing there is nothing that there
is nothing that fuels the vindictiveness
of a woman like simpish Behavior I don't
know why this is but the more simpish
you were during the marriage the more
she wants to take from you it is it is
absolutely unbelievable and it's amazing
a lot of times women divorce their
husbands because they catch them
cheating
they they do they almost never and a lot
of times they do go for everything they
have but they're so much more vindictive
to the men that treated them better
well thank you for coming on the podcast
absolutely very much thank you um I'm
sure we'll do more of these when I'm in
I love this studio
this studio is freaking awesome yeah
this they they rent it out so if you
ever need one in Miami yeah yeah I'm
gonna I'm actually gonna do a podcast
with the with the owner of the studio uh
right after this one cool well thank you
for coming
um tell them about your your stuff you
know yeah yeah so um yeah I'm on I'm on
YouTube hold on I'm gonna I'm gonna pull
this up he's been doing this since I was
in high school so he wants someone that
someone that knows his stuff yes yes I
have been I have been yes yes yes I just
uh yeah
yes yes I was trying to give you
credibility yeah well I have my
signature course is womanies what she
says versus what she means over 600
translations you can get that at
tsracademy.com and I have my own private
streaming platform with all of my
content and uncensored ad free at
sharpstream.com I saw my books and
courses and offer three free ebooks
academy.com use promo code new 50 to get
50 off and you can find me on locals or
patreon just look for Donovan Sharp
thank you Donovan uh you guys like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time